Donald Trump is now claiming to be the
new Elvis during a bizarre Gong Show
interview with real America's voice John
Frederick's radio network that's a lot I
don't know exactly what that is it's a
lot of different things here is Trump
based on the popularity of the song that
features Trump benefiting the January
6th rioters Trump says he's almost like
the new Elvis thanks for being here I
want to ask you whether I should call
you Mr President or I saw you on Hannity
the other night saying you're the new
Elvis I helped put that song Together
Justice for All uh how does it feel to
be number one on the billboard chart sir
right well you know who are is the j6
prisoners they're number one because
they asked me if I do that and the money
goes to them and it's a beautiful thing
and it was number one on every chart
including billboard
it was it started off on iTunes and it
went to Amazon and Trump really sounds
like he knows what those things are
doesn't he and it hit billboard
is Miley Cyrus and Molly Molly I'm very
honest I said maybe I'm the new Elvis we
now have now that we've gone into show
business with the apprentice and now we
do this
covered a lot of territory in a life
yeah this dude's really weird I have to
say folks that song benefits the
insurrectionists think about that for a
moment and then Trump really gets into
the wacky stuff here he hits DeSantis
again and says that desantis's bubble
has already popped and he was out of
politics if I didn't
yeah and then he said yeah
he had about running against Trump I
said is that the way it works because
there's something about loyalty that I
like you know there it is loyalty
loyalty Above All Else Trump's loyal to
no one but everyone must be loyal to him
like it maybe I like it too much but the
fact is that yeah his his bubble has
popped I believe but but you know you
never know you never know you got to be
careful could be popped like a balloon
and then maybe most tragically
when the Nashville Tennessee school
shooting was brought up to Donald Trump
no he didn't attack me like his son Don
Jr did that's not what Trump did
although I was worried for a moment
there
Trump's idea is
give guns to the teachers
yeah pardon me they're saying that this
shooter uh went to another school first
and saw there was too much security so
then went to the Christian School which
had less security what would you do as
president to finally make sure our
children are safe and get trained I mean
there are retired military people and
Karen showed me I shared a video with
you yesterday saying we'll come forward
we'll protect her children there are
people out there willing to do more law
enforcement retired military so go ahead
sir
features that are very good with guns
because you really want them to where
they can handle it and you have teachers
that have a great you know record
they're in the military and everything
else and they're in the school and you
can do that with a you know with it you
don't need a very big percentage you
take the people that are really Adept
with guns a lot of people have been
talking
this concept I threw this out too but
you have people that are very good with
weapons and guns yeah the same teachers
who can't choose which books the
children are allowed to read they can't
be trusted to choose the books the
parents need to decide about the books
those are the teachers we're going to
give the guns to and this is the
solution that they're offering that
could be you know if they're right there
are on the spot and you could have that
they could put them in safely someplace
but very very near I and if you had
something like that happen they take
them out truly pathetic I mean truly
truly disturbing so as usual I mean
listen guys we're now five days out from
the shooting
uh as usual there is no serious
conversation being had about doing
something about gun safety in fact
they're saying there should be more guns
and by the way if you suggest that
prayers don't prevent shootings you
become the focus as I did for the last
week
the tragic reality of this is
it makes sense I'm kind of like
struggling with the right way to say
this
it's logical if you've been paying
attention for the last 20 years since
Columbine however it's been longer even
if you've been paying attention for the
last few decades it would be logical to
say I give up
I don't think this is fixable it doesn't
seem fixable because they don't want to
do anything about guns the culture
glorifies violence more and more
mental health may be a factor but they
don't want to fund that
we have no it's done we're just not
going to be able to solve it
and yet that doesn't square with the
fact that we have to solve it and many
people including those who are parents
say we we can't just give up right can't
we or do we need to move to another
country but that's not possible for so
many people so on the one hand it's like
logical that you would say I give up
there's no solution but you also really
can't do that because what that means is
we are conceding it's just going to
continue being like this and that's
completely unacceptable I don't know
where to go next with it let me know
your thoughts leave a comment send an
email we will follow up quick break back
after this with much more and I want to
hear from you as well I know many people
have been itching to call in all week